hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control ac.l2 Dot Dash
dot dash dot dash 3.1.18 control
connections and mobile devices
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all of the
cmmc dfars and nist SP 800 171
compliance stuff on top of an already
colossal workload well I've got great
news for you you've found your home here
at on-call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform into your
company's on-call compliance Hero Let's
jump into it so in cmmc control
ac.l2-3.1.18 control connection of
mobile devices what we are trying to
figure out here is hey do you have
control over mobile devices and their
ability to connect to your system and
access cui obviously mobile devices can
represent a huge threat to information
security especially if they are hooked
up to a wireless network now let's check
out what the assessors are really
looking for and how to make them happy
now uh if I'm an assessor there are
three points that I'm looking to assess
on number one determine if mobile
devices that process store or transmit
cui are identified now if I gave a
sample answer maybe a sample answer
looks like something like this all
network devices which assess cui are
identified in active directory maybe
they're in active directory maybe
they're in InTune maybe they are in a
written inventory in the it office who
knows but somehow they've got to be
identified
then we want to determine if mobile
device connections are authorized
conditional so if I was to give a sample
answer uh conditional access policies
are in use in order to allow mobile
device access in addition only the CIO
uh or coo or someone in it is authorized
to set up MFA or multi-factor
authentication which tokenizes each
individual device to allow access now
there's a lot to unpack there I'm not
going to do in this video if you've got
questions reach out give us a call but
again the idea is to determine how uh
you know if if those mobile device
connections are actually authorized
right and there's a lot of different
ways a lot of different solutions in
fact on the market to do that now third
point is determine if mobile device
connections are monitored and logged all
right now we get the little tie in with
our seam system so if we give a sample
answer we would say hey look mobile
device connections are in fact monitored
and logged via the same solution or
security information event management so
again if you don't know what that is
reach out to us for help but we talk
about a lot throughout our videos
because it's a big piece of being
compliant and of course and on call we
work with defense contractors just like
you who have had this dfar's nist itar
and cmmc compliance stuff dropped in
their laps like a seagull on a sunny day
we teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins that's what
I'm talking about now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero
could do for you and that's what we
specialize in hey if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmc complianceecrets.com
or check out the bio below for links to
get help right now love the content
we're putting out here for you help us
out with a big thumbs up on that like
button or even better smash the
Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance centers roll it out until the
next compliance tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there and hit us in the
comments below and let us know what
you'd like to know more about when it
comes to information security and
compliance and I'll see you on the next
one
[Music]
foreign